dozens of countries are looking to china
to rescue them from the covet 19
pandemic
that's because the chinese government
has pledged to donate nearly
half a billion vaccines worldwide
after its failure in handling the
initial outbreak and
spread of covet 19 beijing is eager to
repair its
image in the world vaccine diplomacy
could potentially be the face saving
tactic to
change the narrative and expand its
drive for global influence
in a europe ravaged by covid 19
this is what hope looks like belgrade
serbia waiting in line for liberation
from the pandemic
but these injections are about more than
public health
they were flown in from china to a
presidential welcome
chinese state tv on hand to capture the
moment
just the latest part of a massive
pandemic rebranding exercise
that mixes medical assistance with
disinformation
we have seen some
quite sustained efforts also
to try to spin the debate in a way that
makes it look like
it didn't start in china and china was
you know
only the first country to report it
what's happening here is something that
goes well beyond a pandemic
and far exceeds the scope of china's
official diplomatic missions like here
in berlin
it's a much bigger campaign for global
influence
that's been building up for years and
will continue
long after the pandemic is over the most
visible driver of this is the belt and
road initiative
a project spanning more than a hundred
countries that is redrawing the map of
china's economic power
in a single region in europe chinese
funds are pouring into
highway bridges in montenegro a
coal-fired power plant in bosnia
and a giant seaport in greece that may
yet become the largest in europe
and you can see signs that these
investments can translate into political
influence
like at the united nations human rights
council
where china won a show of support last
year for its controversial suppression
of freedoms in hong kong
four out of five countries backing china
had signed up
to belton road efforts to shape global
perceptions come
right from the very top china's
president xi jinping was the opening
speaker at this year's virtual
davos meeting exuding confidence and
positioning beijing
as the world's greatest champion of
global cooperation
there is a strong desire to show the
superiority of you know the chinese
system
to set to give
examples that show why perhaps in the
20th century democracies were
cute and useful and good but now for the
21st century the only systems that are
really suitable to face the challenges
of this century
are systems that are closer to the
chinese system
us president joe biden has made his
debut on the world stage vowing to push
back at that idea
saying democracy will and must prevail
germany's angela merkel says that the
west must now engage in this unfolding
competition
it's important that it's not only china
and russia that are delivering vaccines
to developing countries
the unfixings it might seem like madness
that lining up for a vaccine can mean
picking sides in a geopolitical battle
but that is shaping up to be our new
reality
a battle for influence and even ideas
about nothing less than how to run the
world
a report by dw's chief international
editor richard walker who
joins us now richard we heard in your
report that beijing is promoting a
counter-narrative about the origins of
the pandemic trying to convince people
it didn't start in china
is it gaining any traction with that
effort
well terry it's really too early to say
in this phase where we're talking about
vaccines diplomacy at the moment
obviously this has really only just
begun but
the latest research that we do have from
just towards the end of last year from
pew research just showed that especially
in western countries or countries
that are members of the kind of
democratic community of the west
they have a massive image problem so
negative evaluations of china in the uk
in germany and the netherlands in sweden
in the us in south korea
in france in canada in australia and
japan all of those countries
over 70 percent of respondents over 80
in some cases said that they had
negative views of china
now this isn't all about the pandemic a
lot of this goes back to things that
have been happening
over the last couple of years the real
surge you've seen is over the last two
or three years
talking about what we've seen the
suppression of political rights in hong
kong
accusations of genocide over actions in
xinjiang against the muslim minority
there within china so
there are a lot of reasons for these
negative views of china at the moment
but
the covert pandemic has certainly been
the latest kind of icing on the cake
so china's vaccine diplomacy which we
saw there in your report is obviously
making some inroads
particularly in developing countries
critics may point to questionable ethics
there but isn't it true
that china is filling a gap that western
countries have not
that's absolutely right i mean if you
look at the vaccination situation in the
west
particularly in europe it's really not a
pretty picture and in two ways
first of all governments are getting
accused particularly in europe are being
far too
slow at vaccinating their populations
getting the vaccines rolled out
far too slowly and but at the same time
if you look at the actual numbers
european governments are massively
prioritizing their
own people and so the united states
compared to say the developing world
now there is this international
initiative called kovacs which has a lot
of
very high profile sign-ups germany is a
very prominent supporters poured quite a
bit of money into that but kovacs has
just announced its latest its first
rather
initial allocation of vaccines to
developing countries around the world
they're talking about uh an allocation
of 237 million vaccines
well think about what the european union
has ordered it says it's ordered 2.6
billion for the european union alone so
237 million for the developing world 2.6
billion for the european union you're
absolutely right there is
a wide open door that china and of
course russia as well are walking
through
should we expect this crisis richard to
allow china to expand its foothold in
europe
well of course we've been talking quite
a bit about developing countries that uh
china's both its vaccine drive and its
belt and road initiative kind of
primarily
uh focus say on the global south you
could say
but it's also looking at countries
within central and eastern europe sort
of countries that are either on the
periphery of the european union or
relatively new members of it
take hungary for example uh victor orban
the
strongman prime minister of hungary
recently uh
was became the only eu leader to order
uh the sino-farm vaccine chinese vaccine
into hungary
he took a shot of it himself saying that
he trusted it
more than the western vaccines now that
is a
huge boon for the chinese government
that's something that they can play back
home to uh to the domestic audience
showing here's a western leader saying
that they trust uh foxy
but also that is a foothold within
europe and that is something that we've
seen
um over recent years china trying to
kind of pick off
countries within europe that it can
build favorable relations
with countries that can then support it
in international foreign like we saw in
the report there
and chipping away at the unity of the
west which is very much
a long-term objective of china and also
russia
richard thank you so much dw's richard
walker there
you